champion olympique regard adore ses mots
résonnent
ces mots sont plus tôt
une réussite quand on associe le mot
store au terme porno dans l'intention
collective on a plutôt une image
positive peut penser qu'un de la
génétique des capacités mais ça peut
faire envie parfois même rêver et comme
les petits drones et bien toutes les
étapes pour en arriver là ne sont pas
aussi blancs si on observe bien les
belles alan en croix et informer les
deux sont liés l'un doit jamais ce coup
là et comme la médaille a son revers
tout système à sa perversion
victoires/défaites liberté privations
sauf que là ce n'est qu'après coup que
lancera encore de la perversion d'un
système contre avant la médaille qui
elles de manière physique nous rappelle
que les dés sont liés dans le sport
comme vous le disait parce que peut-être
chiffré à commencer par votre potentiel
et c'est souvent là beaucoup des
problèmes pour deux raisons la première
c'est que tout le monde joue en main
c'est de combien vous êtes le monial et
vous avec une espèce de poker dans le
dow affiche et compte sur toi et
implicitement je n'ai pas le choix je
dois réussir la deuxième chose c'est que
vous même vous rendez cours de votre
pensée de votre potentiel vous avez
vraiment la perception et vous comprenez
que vous pourrez scandale carrière sauf
que ce qu'on a envie de vous dire c'est
que le potentiel ne suffit plus comme on
rentre dans la cour des grands le talent
de la plupart leur si elle ne
s'accompagne pas de travail en plus dans
les années saignant d'après vos 18 ans
quand vous affrontez d'érable a beaucoup
plus âgés donc expérimenté longues
plumes intérêts et pour les tous
meilleurs avec les capacités restent
identiques aux vôtres donc à faire vous
avez la possibilité de faire deux choix
soit de prendre la première voie celle
qui travaillent ceux de prendre la
seconde à dia la petite porte parole
bon encore une fois la jauge de la
chance c'est que j'ai jamais eu
l'impression l'environnement il n'est
jamais
amis ni l'entraîneur qui ont essayé de
vivre leurs ventes sur trois
configurations
non ça toujours été un choix personnel
et beaucoup sacrifié d'hypothéquer
énormément de choses pour voir si ça
marcherait mais surtout pour éviter de
nourrir des regrets dans 20 30 40 ans si
j'avais pas réalisé on disait on sport
presque tout est chiffré les chiffres
ont leur mot à dire
c'est souvent ce qui avance qui préside
la performance alors est ce que c'est
une bonne chose
je m'en servirai et ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'ils peuvent impressionner
il peut aussi faire peur démoralisé
effrayer si je reviens un petit peu sur
ma carrière
cette médaille d'or olympique on a dit
entendre que celle là qu'est ce que ça
représente
clément cumuler sa présence lui 4
millions de contrats en cumulé ça
représente un tour du monde à la rame en
cumulé sa présence en france ouvrira
plus de 40 0 à 3 181 et psychique qui
finalement l'impression et cachent
d'autres parce que l'avion est un sport
amateur qui m'appelle suivant des études
travail en plus de mon activité on va
dire sportif c'est donc pendant plus de
dix ans me lever tous les matins pour
les membres ont traîné quelles que
soient les conditions météo le franc le
froid le vent la pluie la vague c
pendant plus de dix ans presque jamais
voir mes parents c'est pendant que dix
ans presque compter sur les doigts d'une
main et sur l'entrepôt et ce manque d
amour de jeunesse
c'est chaque saison pendant plus de dix
ans perdent entre six et huit kilos
parce que et parce que j'appartenais à
la catégorie collégiens étaient c'est ce
qu'on a posé la réglementation l
enseigne qui dure qui dure bien sûr car
au-delà de la remontée justement de
prouver ce que je vais j'étais en
mission et je crois que je devais faire
parce que la nature marquées pour et si
je me suis mis ça en tête
ces pages visant les fondements de la
métaphysique des moeurs des plantes en
fait c'est juste en les quittant la
grand mère laura côté que pendant son
enfance elle pas forcément cette farce
qu'elle aurait voulu lui mettre un petit
texte
voilà ça c'est un document que j'ai
scanné il a trouvé après son décès
donc qui date du mercredi 22 qui l'a
redit tous novembre 1941 les points
qu'elle a 13 ans je vous passe la
lecture dans ce travail d'expression
écrite elle explique qu'en fait son rêve
ce serait de devenir professeur
d'éducation physique
sauf que l'avenir me réserve à autre
chose rapidement que son certificat
d'études à la lui a arrêté sa scolarité
est directement allé travailler pour eux
est la sienne quinze ans plus tard parce
que 20 à son premier enfant seul cas
plus élevé pendant cinq six ans seul
tout en continuant à travailler
et ouais sans sac avec leurs nobles
allemands - parce que dans les années 50
avoir un enfant seule les vaisseaux tout
en continuant à travailler
non c'est sorti un petit public a donc
moi qui avais toutes ses capacités à la
base et qui rien ne l'empêché j'avais
finalement aucune excuse pourquoi
n'aurait on va dire ce cadeau qui m'a
été fait on peut être en larmes
mais on peut aussi de devenir ce sont
deux choses complètement différentes
on peut le devenir même si on ne l'était
pas forcément à la base même si le
destin vous a privé de quelques
occasions en définition de l'être humain
est en larmes nous sommes différents
nous ne sommes pas des clones et j'ai
même plus loin
être hors norme c'est notre obligation
d'être humains pour que notre publicité
participent à notre objection au
collectif qui lui par contre ne propose
que des référentiels communs personnes
répondent point alors si je reprends les
trois catégories on peut pas toutes
celles des mozart d'einstein bolt
et nous avons toutes les capacités dans
un domaine est souvent moins explorés ça
peut être le meilleur par famille est le
meilleur collègues de boulot être le
meilleur pour juin alors c'est quoi
votre mission
ainsi
[Applaudissements]